Jacob is in Modesto California hi Jacob
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how you
doing it better than I deserve what's up
in your world all right so I am in
35,000 in debt between cars credit cards
personal loans and just minutes
miscellaneous like phone bills but
didn't pay and and stuff like that so I
currently got a new job pays forty-five
thousand I'm currently two weeks in the
job so I'm necessarily a job I like but
I know I need to pay down this set I
have a baby on the way about a month
away due in a month and it scares me
mm-hmm good let's call some man it means
you're gonna be a good dad it's just
scary should scare you just a little bit
it's it's a scary thing being a dad and
it's a good thing being a dad cool well
so 45,000 and so the reason the bills
weren't paid is you didn't have a job um
I've been out of the job maybe for about
one month now and that guys are like
behind on your phone bill and that kind
of stuff right yes okay here's what I
want you to do when the baby's due in a
month so she's eight months right yeah
cool how old are you guys
I'm 22 she's 20 this is your first baby
right yeah awesomeness okay fine well
congratulations
here's what we're gonna do number one
we're gonna get on a written budget go
to every dollar and download the app
it's free and I want you to build out
your budget on the every dollar app okay
okay completely free you and your wife
sit down and do that tonight every
dollar of your new income has an
assignment the first assignment is food
for the house you have to eat for you
can do anything right yes the second
one's pay the light bill are you behind
on your light bill your water bill so
currently I moved from Texas are you on
your light bill in your water bill it's
a yes or no answer no okay good you're
current on that if you got old bills
back in Texas we'll deal with those
later but I'm talking about I want to
keep your lights on and food on your
table those are first two things as a
dad
third things keep the table there the
shelter so are you current on your
current rent where you live now that's
what I was saying before I live with
family so in Texas I had my own place
and for the baby's sake I wanted to be
close to family and okay so you don't
have rent or lights no sir okay good
that's good news right now and so you do
have food one way or the other either
family's going to help or you can put it
on the table right and how much debt do
you have not how much debt do you have
so in all its thirty five thousand okay
are you current are you behind on it
you're behind on the phone bill we know
that that phone bill and one credit card
okay so the only thing I want you to do
in your budget right now is feed your
family and give shelter to your family
which it sounds like that's taken care
of right now and I want you to get
current I do not want you to pay any
extra I want you to save as much money
as you can save until the baby comes
how big a pile of money can you possibly
save in the next month and a half or so
okay because any little bit of extra
money in savings makes you makes the
delivery much more peaceful okay because
baby step one if you've been doing any
the Dave Ramsey stuff at all yet is save
$1,000 you're not going to have a ton
more than that with your income in in a
month and a half you might have a little
bit more but as much as you can save and
when baby and Momma come home from the
hospital and everybody's healthy then I
want you to take everything except
$1,000 and start throwing it on your
debts and start working your way through
your debts how long do you plan to live
with your family honestly I was thinking
until I was debt free and then renting a
place at first until I can get a down
payment on a house then that sounds like
a good plan to me
and how much debt did you say you have
total again tell me 35,000 how much
about your car because one of the cars
is 20,000 and I do want to sell that one
to it you know I've been listening to a
lot of your advice and I just think I'd
be played on five grand yeah okay okay
then you eat that to borrow that five
grand or save that five grand to get out
of that car right yeah did you have to
give them the whole twenty thousand to
get the title when a buyer gives you 15
yeah yeah so let's get rid of that car
it doesn't fit in your equation anyway
you're living with your parents have a
brand-new baby and make $45,000 a year
in Modesto California you don't need a
$20,000 car note that does not in this
equation so a second job I was thinking
about a second job but right now in my
life a baby coming oh did you get a
second job okay I just want to be able
to see her every now and then either
well you don't I mean you got a month
and a half right right you don't deliver
pizzas for a month and a half like a
crazy man let's see how much money you
can pile up what you'll find is is that
you'll be able to do everything you'll
be able to work hard and be there for
your kids
I've worked like a maniac my life
through my life and all of my kids are
functional none of them are currently
seeing a therapist
due to their father's hard work it
didn't kill any of them okay now what
that means though is is when you're home
you're home you don't sit and watch HBO
you read to your kid and you throw a
brick through your television we don't
throw a brick through your dad's
television you're staying with him but
you don't turn on the television right
you go to the other room you spend time
with your kid when you're home with your
kid what happens is people go I need to
be home to be nurturing and then they're
sitting on their butt watching HBO they
know everything about Game of Thrones
and hadn't read to their own kid that's
what goes out there when people talk
about nurturing that's a bunch of crap
as what it is so if you'll spend the
time at home with the family then it
doesn't take nine hours a day at home to
be a good dad you don't have to do that
to be nurturing it works out just fine
so I was home for all the proms I was
home for all the major tournaments even
when major tournaments our six year old
soccer tournaments which there's nothing
major about that I'll just tell you and
you know all the birthdays I made you
know we scheduled live events around
birthdays and all that kind of stuff but
then when I was when I was at work I was
at work and then enabled the Ramsey
family to do a lot of cool stuff and I
started when I was your age you're gonna
be a great dad
I'm proud of you you're gonna do really
really good you got the right kind of
heart you're already thinking you're
talking the right way
and you're a really young guy you've got
a really bright future ahead of you hold
on I'm going to send you a copy of the
book Total Money Makeover to help you
walk your way right through all this
you're gonna do just fine good question
sir